KYLE KEANE: All right,
litigious stuff out of the way,
the next thing
I'm going to do is
talk a little bit about
what the class is,
how it's going to be
structured, what you can expect.
Because many of you showed up
here to learn Unity, I imagine.
And there will be some
learning of Unity.
But also the great
service of coming together
is to get to know other people
and to work with other people.
So the next two weeks is about
learning some new people's
names, learning
how to communicate
with them about the thing
that you want to build,
working with other
people to come up
with a collaborative vision.
So it's not just about sitting
and watching a tutorial
and learning how to do the
technical aspects of things.
We are gathered here
and I feel like we
should take advantage of that.
Again the, point
of doing this is--
and it's OK.
I'm sorry.
If you lose three
hours today and you
decide that you don't want
to be a part of this class
because I want you guys to talk
too much and stuff like that,
no hurt feelings.
It's no problem.
There's video tutorials.
I'll point you to
great resources.
If you want to come
work with other humans,
this is the place to be.
So the next thing I'm
going to talk about
while Mark emotionally
prepares to start teaching
is what to expect over
the next two weeks.
And so today we are going
to have a brief intro.
I'm thinking you have
some interest stuff
you want to go over, right?
MIKE: Sure.
KYLE KEANE: Sure, all right.
So a brief intro
and then groups.
You're going to get
into small groups.
Now that you have heard some
things about other people,
I'm going to
encourage you to like
try to make eye contact
with others at points
and sit down next to smiley
people and work with them.
So we're getting
into small groups
and we're going to go through
the Roll-a-Ball tutorial, which
is on the Unity website.
But it makes it so much more fun
when you have friends to do it.
So I'll tell you a little bit
more about what you will do.
You'll sit down in a group
of like three or four.
One of you will
volunteer your computer
to be the one where
you watch the video.
The rest of you will open
up Unity on your computer.
And then you will go
through the tutorial
together and make sure
everyone has a chance
to actually like move the
mouse and click on the thing
and do that.
And you're going
to pause it when
it feels natural and right.
And you're going to
challenge each other
to do small modifications.
Like they're going to have
you put a ball on the screen
and you're going to
say to your friend,
hey, try to make it blue.
Hey, try to make four balls.
Hey, try to do this.
And you're going to try to make
it a little more interactive
and fun within a small group.
And you're going to do
that for about two hours.
And hopefully it will be fun and
you'll bond and it'll be cute.
If you end up in a group that
you don't like, no worries.
Tomorrow you'll
form a new group.
So tomorrow you will
have been exposed to--
and this is the tutorial.
It's so well--made and it's
crafted to teach people Unity
for the first time.
And then tomorrow
we're going to come in
and we're going to do
something to make ourselves
feel a little less shy.
And we're going to
say our names again
so maybe people will feel
more comfortable looking us
in the eye and connecting.
And then we're going to
talk about something.
I forget.
There's a 30-minute thing where
am I going to talk to you.
I try not to talk
a lot because I
believe in learning by
doing rather than learning
by listening.
So I will talk minimally.
And then you will
get into groups
and start to extend
the Roll-a-Ball.
So I believe a
very effective way
to learn a new thing--
this class is structured
for people who don't have any
experience doing anything.
So if that feels like you,
you are in the right spot.
If you feel like you're
way too advanced for this,
then have fun interacting with
other people and teaching.
Because when you
teach, you learn a lot
and you get to talk to
people, which is fun.
So tomorrow you'll
extend Roll-a-Ball
in whatever way seems
appropriate for you
and your group.
And then Wednesday and Thursday
we'll do some mini projects.
So we'll get into a third
configuration of humans
into groups of three or
four, probably three.
And you'll think of, hey, I
want to do a small type of game.
And you're probably going
to be crazy ambitious
and you're going to be
like, in the next two days,
I'm going to make this
thing for the Hololens
which allows you to notice
when there's flies flying
across the room because I
have this backend that does AI
and you're going to go nuts.
I hope so.
And then you're going to spend
two days trying to build it
and you're going to be
able to get a screen
to have a picture on it.
And then you'll be
able to prepare--
be prepared to make
a bigger project
and have it scoped properly.
That's my hypothesis.
It works very well
in Arduino and I
think it's going to work
very well here, too.
So Thursday and Friday you'll
have five in-class hours
to work on a small project and
to try to build with a team
and see if you have
a good team dynamic.
And if you don't,
know her feelings.
We're going to
break back up, form
into final groups on Friday.
And from Friday
and next week, you
will be left alone with
guidance and consultations.
If you have questions,
we're here to help.
But you'll be pretty much
left alone in your final group
to design and build a game.
So on Friday we'll do some
type of brainstorming activity
where people who want to
build a certain type of game
will come up and be like,
hey, hololens, holla lens--
OK, that's bad.
I'm sorry.
So, yeah.
And so you'll pitch
your idea and then
you'll break up into groups
and you'll have a week
to build a game together.
And then on Friday
of this next week
we will have a big
public demo day.
So we're going to have
some systems set up
with computers that have
Unity on them with a monitor
and have a Kinect sensor bar.
Oh, yeah, that's also what
we're going to talk about here.
We're going to tell
you how to connect
your game to the Kinect.
So if you want to have people
be able to like jump around
in front of your game,
you'll be able to do that.
And, yeah, so we will have four
systems set up with Kinects
and we will invite people
to come play the games
from outside of the world.
And you will get to
play each other's games
and you'll do little
presentations.
And hopefully it will
be a fun experience.
Any questions about that?
So today you are
having to sit there.
And I'm sorry.
I go crazy when I have to
sit for more than 30 minutes.
I know you're sitting
there very patiently.
But it won't be like this
for the rest of the week.
This is just get to
know each other day.
Yeah, any questions about this?